big changes could soon be coming to the
Clark County School District when it
comes to keeping students safe and
leaders are asking for the money to fund
these ideas thank you for joining us at
six I'm Brian Loftus and I'm Denise
Valdez School leaders asking the state
for 21 million dollars in the name of
student safety eight news now education
reporter Joshua baguero Joins us to look
at the changes coming as early as next
school year Joshua now Brian Denise
School leaders were joined by multiple
Valley law enforcement agencies today
the district is exploring putting in
Place several security enhancements at
the start of the next school year
including clear backpacks
this is not normal
our schools must be safe environments
where children can learn and grow there
are less than 10 school days left before
kids go on summer recess but already the
district has seized 30 guns and 182
knives on campuses kids as young as 6
and 10 were caught with guns
unacceptable numbers for me as an
educator
and as a father we've previously
reported on that of the district shared
showing from the start of the school
year to mid-February school police have
made 94 arrests 30 for battery and
assaults 29 arrests for fights and 23
for harassment threats police have also
issued more than 600 citations and the
schools with the most citations Legacy
Cheyenne and Sunrise Mountain leaders
urged parents to watch what their kids
are doing I'm hoping that this is the
end that we can end these last eight
days without any more incidents
happening in and around our schools
involving our students the district
plans to roll out metal detectors in
August as part of a pilot program just
this week a CCSD employee was shot by a
straight Bullet at Von tobel Middle
School sources closely the investigation
say the shooting is Gang Related it's
not normal to walk out and see crime
scene tape on a regular basis or hear a
helicopter fly over your neighborhood in
the middle of the night every night
now also address threats of a school
shooting circulating on social media 8
news now first reported as a hoax on
Friday it originated in Florida
officials urge students not to share it
Denise